well I'm in the south guy remember so
you don't have to so it's come to this
[Music]
Tom and Jerry and Willy Wonka and the
Chocolate Factory that's a lot of hands
for this title and one of them should
clearly not be there at goddamn oh I
like Tom and Jerry I like Willy Wonka
but similar to welcome Lea divorced
parents just because I like them
individually does not mean they
shouldn't say miles away from each other
I talked about Willy Wonka and Tom and
Jerry at great length on this show so
figures we should look over their latest
cash grab of inconvenience and for those
not aware this is not the first time
something like this has happened with
Tom and Jerry they've taken a strange
direction the past couple of years in
that there is no direction they're now
tied in with classic stories turned into
classic films despite there being
absolutely no connection there almost
line for line they just somehow sneak
Tom and Jerry into their nobody care too
much as these properties were so big and
so overused that nothing really seemed
that surprising but something about this
one wrote the Internet bonkers maybe
because cinematically Willy Wonka has
only two versions even though it's for
kids it still holds a slightly cynical
edge that seems to be strangely
contemporary even though it came out
years and years ago being lovingly
satirized and referenced even today so
is this the film to suck out that unique
edge from a timeless classic well yeah
this is Tom and Jerry and Willy Wonka
and the Chocolate Factory
oh it's just like watching a Tom and
Jerry cartoon this should make all the
Willy Wonka fans happy oh it's just like
watching Willy Wonka they should make
all the Tom and Jerry fans happy you see
the problem you for two seconds
yep this is mostly a shot-for-shot
retelling of the original film Christ I
thought it gave the Beauty and the Beast
reboot a hard time though at least
everybody can sing in this one funny
enough the opening is funny enough yeah
Tom and Jerry do some slapstick chasing
each other around looking for food and
it's not badly done even Tom scream
seems curiously appropriate but serious
Kate's into a candy store and with no
tie in or even introduction the Candy
Man song begins who can take a son
sprinkle it with you quite this is as
well woven as a web that's trying to
ensnare and kill you come on it's a
shot-for-shot remake if you couldn't
even animate that kid getting whacked
with a counter wait spoke too soon this
is already weird the mouse crapping
candy pretending there's a cycle
something else you'll notice is that for
what it is the animation clearly has
effort put into it it's colorful smooth
get chunks of the slapstick right it's
not half bad but then you realize it's
not half good either at for all its
talent it still looks rushed out and
most likely there was no time to redo a
drawing if one looks slightly off
because of this I'm gonna do my face is
eating your soul while you look at them
count
who's happy going to start off with
Charlie totally ignores the fact that
free candy is being handed out and it's
been stopped Tom from eating Jerry I had
to do that I couldn't let you eat that
poor Mouse thank you can't be that bad
can they think don't you encourage that
we all know where this mindset leads
Charlie feels bad for the both of them
being hungry so he gives them the bread
that he was gonna give his family well
wait then how does the later sing go
grandpa George grandma Georgina here MA
Josephine grandpa Joe Kevin ya can lean
forward with a little less intensity I'm
tired of cabbage water tonight we're
gonna have a real banquet I had two of
them but I gave one to some new friends
so Georgia Georgina will still eat the
shitty cabbage water but the rest of us
we eat like royalty Tom and Jerry wants
to repay Charlie so they try to sneak
into the candy store and steal a crate
of Wonka bars thankfully the delivery
man is a dog because coherent realities
are dumb Charlie of course tells them
it's not right to steal and they should
return it they put the crate back while
breaking and entering and leaving the
crap out of the staff breaking several
more laws to account for one misdemeanor
my conscience is clear
meanwhile like in the film a big
announcement hits the school well he
wanted to are you just waiting at that
door for someone to open it you look
like you've been practicing that pose
for hours
Willy Wonka's opening up its factory you
got a mine walk of our spine second
class dismissed
that's a Charlie fantasizes about
killing them killing them all
Tommy jury recommend they steal again
that crate they stole before no it's not
nice guys
funny fact this is the artists
interpretation of what hanna-barbera
would think of this now you know the
drill for kids find the golden ticket so
Gustav gloop Veruca Salt Mike TV and
Violet Beauregarde when I heard about
this Wonka thing I switch to chocolate
but then I went through that's another
creepy thing and that last the fifth one
is found by to be fair a pretty humorous
cameo I've never been happier only not
only did they work in the droopy cameo
but they also worked in a Mexican
stereotype to go on the other
stereotypes Tom and Jerry recycled
bottles to get some money to buy a bar
again wondering how payment to animals
works in this ecosystem but the coin
falls down the drain only to be picked
up by Charlie my god all of that was
needed 1 Wonka bar ETS and of course
it's from the crate that Tom and Jerry
had it in a way the fifth golden ticket
is a forgery
Alberto Manuel Assad has just been taken
into custody by the police case what if
that was I am a little disturbed to see
droopy and cops please share for this if
animals can make a living I have no idea
what the water like in this world surely
naturally opens up the bar finding the
last golden ticket after another creep
face
it's grumpy - reaction yeah you probably
get slugworth stopped him and tells
Charlie all about how he wants him to
give an Everlasting Gobstopper from
Wacha but this time there's three big
differences one is he's German you'll
not get a hold of an Everlasting
Gobstopper and bring it to me
so I can find the secret formula we have
one of those stereotypes already thank
you - he moves like the skeleton of a
pink elephant from Dumbo
Everlasting Gobstopper if he's
successful
he'll bankrupt me well I think there's
too many creepy faces to count for this
one we'll just do a quick note third and
it's not easy to say the strangest of
all he seems Farook assault song I want
it now I want it all
what I want is over I want to lock it
all up in my pocket my bar of chocolate
why are you playing this here it only
runs the song later when you play it
again also the other chips didn't get a
song what makes Charlie so special in
fact doesn't it make him see even more
how untrustworthiness gyres it makes no
sense
I want dinner I want the whole bird on
my plate it isn't too late I'm so glad
kids finally have an accordion version
of Pink Floyd's the wall whitworth we
don't need no education now what Charlie
synched him down a sewer because life is
a joke and you showed this family the
ticket causing that faker Grandpa Joe to
suddenly start walking yeah I'm fine
charlie I'm fine
look at me I am never resolved mine oh
now that was a segue I'm fine Charlie I
looked at Mary I never thought my life
to be anything mom catastrophe you're
kind of acting like you knew it wouldn't
thank God we have Tom and Jerry fighting
over this momentous occasion cuz I got a
golden fish it's it's always Charlie
here I go
what's my speed I can't watch your speed
because you're not showing it clearly
does well be one of this miracle
appealing to focus on violence and
maiming if I just showed you this scene
would you think it's about a man who
could walk again or the three of them
committing a murder and don't let the
fact that you're welcoming death
influence you
[Applause]
you
[Music]
normally say they go to the factory
where all the ren and stimpy characters
with their cheeks about to be ripped off
await pointless insert number 12 arrives
as grandpa JA forgets his ticket so Tom
and Jerry use all their power of filler
to get it back to him a bird sees the
ticket and takes it to earn S on top of
a stoplight to use as a pillow how bad
birds do Christ are pilots eyes trying
to leave their sockets we don't even
need an olympus on for her nobody's
gonna wanna do what her creepy ass is
doing what I like about this scene of
Wonka coming up pretending to be
disabled is that unlike the other film
where people just look a little confused
and maybe disappointed the people in
this one are downright past a tame piss
on his horses you know well medicate the
devil he of course tricks them revealing
your ate nightmare tonight Tom and
Jerry's meet the ticket back into Joe's
pocket where can I put it oh my god is
that what I think it is oh thank you
Jesus my lip oh we're guard darling
child okay that wasn't just one drawing
you can't to rise like that while she
was talking isn't trying to hide your
faces of death anymore
[Music]
well wait a minute the dog was on a
leash if they can hold down jobs own
homes and commit crimes why do they
still need to be on the leash your old
building is this game on the Jenga made
out of what toilet paper the Tom and
Jerry seat slugworth and even listen to
his quote unquote
evil plan by the end of the day Charlie
Bucket will get exactly what's coming to
him
and then this Chocolate Factory will
have a new owner
I love critically explaining my good
deeds mo ha ha ha oh look I'm going to
deliver this ice cream to the Children's
Hospital
ha ha ha ha ha so Tom and Jerry sneak in
to stop his quote unquote
evil plan and come across Tuffy as an
oompa-loompa intern don't you know it's
dangerous down here
oh and pretend that hellish bass I had a
second ago but we're never gonna explain
it we end up in the chocolate room again
distracting from the enchanting moment
with more slapstick anything you want to
do it want to change the womb yeah
that's just as creepy an animation as it
wasn't mine action of course the goose
just falls in and get stuck in the pipe
and the Oompa Loompas thing about it
what do you get when you jostle sound
please they don't even have common Jerry
flying off the letters even my shitty
ideas are more inspiring Lee Laney than
your shitty ideas I get to the boat and
Tom and Jerry seem to miss it but
luckily Tuffy has a boat just for him to
catch up Christine I will keep a spare
boat by the river there's so many wives
and so little time I'm just going to
list them here feel free to go back and
look at if you wish they get in the boat
and sure enough they go through the
tunnel ok I'm not going to lie this is
the one scene I'm looking forward to I
just have to know how does insanity
depict insanity what does the reflection
of a reflection look like you can't have
the balls to have them chop off a
chicken's head or say the fires of hell
I
we have no idea what's in that goddamn
thing and I'm surprisingly excited to
see your interpretation of it okay go um
they're having toffee the mouse do this
scene are they actually saying the whole
power of my gosh I know the damage in my
eyebrow what's that a toy dog in the
background is fire the hell up going in
the garbage Jerry cartoon is it glowing
[Music]
did that really just happen no joke this
might actually be more him saying than
the original the first one had people's
fears it wanted to scare and frighten
them this has a tweet dog and boo boo
boo who's also a mouse a kid mouse with
a cute little Lisp in a Tom and Jerry
cartoon where they say the word hell
look I know Gene Wilder is terrifying in
the original but look at me
look at
[Applause]
all right not saying this is better than
the original not by a longshot but I am
saying it's crazier and it's kind of the
best thing of the movie we don't think
that it goes what I'm saying
sadly the boring kind of madness takes
over again as we just see Tom and Jerry
in the background of other famous waka
seas getting the gobstoppers licking the
wallpaper and turning violet into a
blueberry oh come on you couldn't even
really make her look blue it still looks
like a weak light is on her face how do
you do that in animation the only
difference is slugworth and the dog
shave Tom and Jerry around while all of
that is going on it doesn't even make
sense
yt obsess over getting them it happens
during the fizzy lifting drink scene the
gue scene and yes even during the repeat
of the song we already heard today but
what I would do wet it's a totally
different angle I never conserve before
wait it's just stupid why is he even
singing it he doesn't need to convey
he's evil to a cat Mountain Oh biloba oh
he's got the freaky cuddle stick down
how come he doesn't know that's
Longworth isn't a bad guy oh wait maybe
it's because he's doing everything a bad
guy would do and for no literal good
reason he even steals a Gobstopper great
what are you gonna do with it mr. fungi
so the everlasting gasps what to love my
job again Tom and Jerry get stuck with
peruca getting sent to the furnace
[Music]
totally separately twenty three three on
our asses oh my god no no no it doesn't
end there
it ends with this no no not there either
it's Tom and Jerry they just brush it
off occasionally making a black base jam
none in this one that would have been
hard to explain to your kids so not as
hard as this good luck with that parents
my TV gives AK soft next which means
we're probably getting close to the
film's traditional lending to say the
leaf movie take some liberties they're
leaving the factory dad course Wonka
knew they would figure out his
technology and Beaman back changing
their sizes having a death battle
resulting in everyone's insides being
switched around
I mean infinitely playbook y'all my
offer still stands Charlie back with two
gobstoppers
I could ruler the candy world does not
own one not exist anymore now you and I
can be partners our Gobstopper will make
a king of the candy world what is it
with Tom and Jerry and smiling predators
walking slowly towards the camera so
after Charlie's trust is tested its
tested again in the classic scene where
woke up without him we didn't see any
rules wrong sir wrong under Section 37
of the contract signed by him which we
never saw signed oops
you stole fizzy lifting drink so you get
nothing
you lose good day sir
Wow that was the person we came by this
film standards I would have expected at
least three soul-sucking faces out of
that scene of course Charlie leads the
Gobstopper even though honestly should
he's more than earned his trust one kid
should be an asshole now but he revealed
again it was all a test
let me introduce mr. Wilkinson my master
plan was to air Ponca find an heir I was
concerned that you and Tom and Jerry
would interfere with the plan granted
like 99.9% of it made no sense but look
Tom and Jerry are parting bubbles why
question anything walkin naturally gives
Charley the factory and says the final
line would he believe the creepiest face
in the entire movie you know what
happened to the boy who suddenly got
everything he ever wanted he lived
happily ever after
Tom and Jerry
so yeah it's about as bad as you would
think
I'll give it a little credit for
animation that's at least trying even it
doesn't always work looking a while the
slapstick can get a lap and she's right
that tunnel Satan but aside from that
it's a combination that doesn't belong
together resulting in the focus always
being on the wrong thing Willy Wonka
fans will enjoy Tom and Jerry
distracting from the emotional moments
and Tom and Jerry fans will enjoy Willy
Wonka getting in the way of their
chaotic mayhem what can I say but it's a
bad egg I've done this Houser critic and
one more time I think we're all going to
remember that
[Music]
[Applause]
I desire the hell of going
hey Doug Walker here doing the charity
shout out this week we are doing red dot
org red partners with the world's most
iconic brands that contribute up to 50
percent of profits from red branded
goods and services to the Global Fund
red has generated more than four hundred
and sixty-five million dollars for the
Global Fund to fight AIDS a hundred
percent of that money goes to work on
the ground no overhead is taken Global
Fund grants that red supports have
impacted more than 90 million people
with prevention treatment counseling HIV
testing and care services if you check
out their YouTube channel or their site
you can see in great detail all the hard
work they put into this as well as the
millions of people whose lives they've
made better click on the link and you
can show your support and your things
for all the kindness they've shared
[Music]
you